un llamado a la calma por parte del
nuevo presidente de perú pedro castillo
y es que este maestro izquierdista
genera divisiones su eslogan de campaña
no más pobres en un país rico conquistó
gran parte del público rural pero la
derecha lo califica como una amenaza
para la economía miedos que el nuevo
presidente intenta disipar
nosotros estamos haciendo una
convocatoria a todos los técnicos y
comprometidos con el país una de esas
personas podría ser pedro francke su
actual asesor económico y quien se
estima que puede ser el ministro de
economía aunque todavía no se conoce
cómo será el nuevo gabinete
frank que podría traer cierta
tranquilidad para los empresarios pues
diferentes sectores lo respetan por su
experiencia que incluye el banco central
de reserva del perú y el banco mundial
él defiende la llamada economía popular
de mercado que promueve castillo no está
planteado ninguna estatización y
expropiación ni control generales al
precio ni nada de eso hay un cambio sí
porque queremos que las economías
populares mejoren y que esa sean la
prioridad de nuestro gobierno el empleo
la economía las familias y tm tema
económico es la prioridad nuestro
gobierno sin embargo la derechista keiko
fujimori
insiste en que castillo expropiar a las
empresas privadas y amenazar a la
economía de perú que es el segundo mayor
productor de cobre del mundo
pedro castillo y frank que defienden sus
políticas económicas explicando que
utilizarán ingresos del sector minero
para mejorar aspectos como la salud y la
educación de los peruanos